in this video you're gonna learn how to
add and subtract rational expressions by
getting a common denominator we're gonna
go through two examples I'll show you
how this works step by step so the first
thing you want to do is you want to
factor the denominator as much as you
can so let's go ahead and do that first
so this is a difference of two squares
the way we factor that is using a sum
and difference pattern so this is going
to be X plus 2 X minus 2 so let's just
cross that out for now
over here this is a trinomial with a
leading coefficient of 1 we just have to
say what two numbers multiply to
negative 2 but they have to add to that
middle coefficient negative 1 and that's
going to be X minus 2 and X plus 1 if
you need to review my videos on
factoring now the next thing you want to
do is when you look at these
denominators you want to make sure you
get a common denominator so what I
oftentimes do with these is I look at
what's missing what do I need so that
they have the same denominator so if I'm
looking over here I notice that I've got
an X plus 2 and X minus 2 but I don't
have an X plus 1
see like this denominator has so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna multiply the
numerator and the denominator by what's
missing because whatever you do to the
denominator you want to do to the
numerator anything divided by itself
that's like 1 right and so it doesn't
change the value of this fraction over
here now you can see that it's got an X
minus 2 and X plus 1 but it's missing an
X plus 2 so what I'm gonna do is go over
here and multiply the numerator and
denominator by what's missing which is X
plus 2 again anything divided by itself
is 1 1 times that original fraction
doesn't change the value of the fraction
it's just changes the way that it looks
now when you look at this denominator
here in this denominator here you can
see that they're exactly the same so now
we can combine these together into one
fraction with the common denominator of
X minus 2 X plus 1 and X plus 2 so let's
go ahead and make one big fraction I'm
going to distribute the 2 here this is
going to be 2x plus 2 over here now I'm
going to distribute the 3 that's going
to give us 3x plus 6 but you see this
subtraction sign here this is where
students sometimes go off track a little
bit you're subtracting this whole
quantity so you don't want to put it in
parenthesis an alternative that you
might like is that you
think of this as instead of - you can
think of it as like adding the opposite
so I can think of this as like plus a
negative 3 and then I could just
distribute the negative 3 that'd be
negative 3x minus 6 which is the same
thing we're to get here when we
distribute the negative we're gonna get
negative 3x minus 6 okay so now all we
have to do is combine like terms 2x plus
a negative 3x is negative 1 X 2 plus
negative 6 is negative 4 and then it's
going to be all over this common
denominator X minus 2 X plus 1 X plus 2
now just a little note here sometimes
when you go ahead and combine these into
one fraction you can factor the
numerator further in this case I could
factor out a negative 1 that would give
me let's see negative 1 times X plus 4
and the reason you want to do that is
because sometimes factors in the
numerator will cancel with factors in
the denominator and then you could
reduce it down further in this case that
doesn't happen so this I would consider
our final answer let's go on an example
number 2 okay now example number 2 this
one's a little bit different because
we've got a monomial here we've got like
a binomial times a monomial here what
you can do another alternative is you
can break down these quantities as much
as you can what I mean by that is like C
10 10 is really like 2 to the 1st times
5 to the first times x squared over here
or C 5 is already a prime number so this
is just 5 to the first times X to the
first times X plus 1 now when you think
about factors factors are the quantities
that are multiplied together see
sometimes people will mistakenly think
of like x + 1 is like a factor like
these but they're really not see this
the whole thing is considered a group
it's a binomial this whole binomials
multiplied by by this monomial okay so
you don't want to think about adding and
subtracting you want to see what's
multiplied together those are the groups
those are the factors okay so what we
want to do is we want to look at when
you're finding the common denominator
you want to find the least common
multiple the one that occurs not the
least even though it's called the least
common multiple you want to find the one
that occurs in them most so here you've
got one two no twos so you're going to
take the one that occurs the most which
we need one two okay here we have a five
one five it's a tie when it's a tie you
take you know in this case it's both 1-5
so we just need 1/5 here we have x
squared that's like 2 X's this is like 1
X we want to take the one that occurs
the most we need 2 X's that's going to
be x squared and here we have X plus 1
we don't have an X plus 1 so here we
need X plus 1 so now you can see 2 times
5 is 10 so let's just change that to 10
x squared times X plus 1 so this is our
common denominator here so we want to
make sure that both these fractions have
that common denominator so let's go
ahead and multiply by what's missing
this one's missing an X plus 1 see now
it matches a tsunami or whatever you do
to the denominator you want to do to the
numerator here this one you see it's got
a 5 but it doesn't have a 2 right and it
has an X but this one has two x's so
we're really missing another ax and
another 2 so I'm going to multiply the
numerator and denominator by 2 acts
that'll give us the 10 x squared times X
plus 1 the common denominator and so now
all we have to do is combine this into
one fraction with that common
denominator and add those numerators so
let's go ahead and distribute the 3x
that's going to give us 3x squared plus
3x over here 4 times 2x is 8x and we're
adding so that's plus 8x let's go ahead
and combine like terms this is going to
give us 11x plus 3x squared all over our
common denominator 10 x squared 10 x
squared times X plus 1 okay now remember
when I was talking about the numerator
you want to see if you can factor it
let's go ahead and do that we can see we
have an X in common here for both of
these so we can factor out an X that's
going to give us 3x plus 11 all over our
common denominator 10 x squared times X
plus 1 you can see here that one of
these X's cancels with one of these X's
leaving one left over and so our final
result here is going to be 3x plus 11
all over 10 x times X plus 1 and
normally I just leave that denominator
factored that's normally how you know
how it's done you don't have to go ahead
and keep multiplying the main thing was
you get the common tab here combine them
together the next step after learning
how to add and subtract rational
expressions is to solve rational
equations again involving getting
common denominators or clearing the
denominator and I talked about that in
that video right there so follow me over
that video and we'll continue on with
this lesson